problèmes acouphènes entre
autres comme l'explique Normand
- Des casques audio, e e e e e s
pourraient avoir été prises
n'importe où dan m m monde.
Vous écoutez beaucoup
de musique?
- Quand même.
- Quand je suis chez moi, non.
C'est vraiment plus genre
le matu u u quand je reviens
de l'école que je l'écoute fort.
- Mais si cette pratique
est banale, on le sait,
Vous savez que ça peut
vous causer des problèmes long ?
- Absolument, c'est comme fumer.
C'est comme les habitudes
comme ça, il faut
- Et ces conséquences, selon
l'Organisation mondiale de la
santé, pourraienécécécécécécécée
de 19 000 jeunes d'une quinzaine
de pays démontre que le quart
des jeunes dans le monde
s'exposent quotidiennement
à des niveaux s
pour leur système auditif,
ce qui représente autour d'un
milliard d'i
SYLVIE HÉBERT, directrice,
programme d'audiologie, UdeM
- L'OMS calcule qu'en 2050, v vs
au niveau mondial qui vont
avoir une perte significative
- Les audiologistes, dit-elle,
voient régulièrement des jeunes,
parfois des adolescents,
qui ont des pertes audrsrsrsrsré
au bruit causées par leurs
habitudes d'écoute musicale.
- Faut comprendre que
ces pertes-là s
et sont à long terme. Donc c'est
sûr qu'on va pas nécessairement
les détecter à un jeune âge,
mais on sait que les niveaux
d'exposition très élevés vont
à un moment donné produire
des pertes irréversibles.
- Au Canada, le seuil de risque
décibels pour une durée maximale
de huit heures par jour.
Dès qu'on franchit ce seuil,
d'exposition et lorsqu'on
atteint des sommets de décibels,
comme le permettentlelelelelelee
ononononon, il faut vraiment
y aller au compte-gouttes.lalalt
les experts, c'est addic
Chez Layton Audio, on vend de
plus en plus de convertisseurs
appareils qu'on installe entre
l'écouteur et le téléphone
pour augmenter la qualité et
Donc c'est un amplificateur
littéralement, portatif.
- Oui. Portatif, exactement.
l'écouteur va jouer plus fort.
- Est-ce que c'est populaire?
- Oui!
- Par contre, de plus en plus de
clients choisissent maintenant
réduisent les sons extérieurs,
ce qui évite d'avoir à augmenter
le volume pour les couvrir.irir,
Layton Audio
- C'est sûr que quelqu'un qui
veut protéger ses oreilles plus
vers un casque qui couvre plus
l'oreille que qu
intra-auriculaire.
- Mais dans les faits, dit-il,
Donc ce que vous me dites,'à'àr
des écouteurs pour enfants,
tous les autres écouteurs
Ils ne peuvent pas nous protége.
- Non.
- Selon L'OMS, il sera p p p p e
devenu maintenant mondial.
- Une des conclusions
de l'étude, c'est qu'il faut
vraiment augmetitititititititits
et alerter les fabricants aussi
de faire baisser les niveaux
de sons parce que ces niveaux
de sonononononononononononononor
des dommages permanents.
- Ici Normand Grondin,
Radio-Canada, Montréal